the reason I came to the GSP is because
I wanted to create some form of
meaningful change in the world I knew I
wanted to come to GSB to dive deeper
into understanding how to Foster the
conditions necessary to drive positive
impact at scale and so you know the
academics the experiential learning the
networks here at GSB would really help
me to do that and Propel my impact
career I knew that I wanted impact to be
some part of my career I knew knew that
I wanted to make sure that I was giving
back to my community that I cared about
and having a positive impact on the
world I came to Standford GSP because I
really care deeply about alleviating
poverty I personally come from
generations of of bluecollar workers
finances were tough for my family
growing up I I want to help families
like mine now and so utilizing the
resources of Stanford and the Stanford
Community to be able to build for
families like mine was an incredible
opportunity that I couldn't pass up what
stford does just so beautifully is
really focus their efforts and support
on the human being behind the issue and
behind the problem we are all here
because we're trying to do something to
change the world for the better what
makes me most proud as a GSP student is
the amount of intentionality and purpose
that my classmates show every day
they're here to make some form of
difference and meaningful difference in
the world to further human civilization
forward to solve climate change to
tackle poverty to make a more Equitable
society and all these types of changes
that they personally really care about
and that they know the world needs we
have a really expansive and inclusive
vision of what impact means it can be
social and environmental impact it can
be across nonprofit and for-profit and
government it can be through operating
and investing so there's a really
diverse range of different paths and
approaches people take but the Common
Thread amongst everyone is working
towards something that's bigger than
themselves and I find that energy to be
really inspiring to be around I'm super
grateful for the support of the center
for social Innovation from my MBA one
year when I applied to and was accepted
into the impact design immersion
Fellowship which is a summerlong
fellowship that gives funding and
support for researching a problem that
we're passionate about and also Greatful
for student loan forgiveness that
Stanford offers for people who are doing
social impact after school too there's
the social impact small grants which is
a little bit of of funding to help you
get started there's programs which award
students who are leaving the GSB and are
going to pursue careers and impact there
were also a ton of opportunities and
fellowships that gave me some of the
financial and tactical experiences and
tools the GSB has trained so many of the
social impact leaders that I look up to
and they've not only accomplished such
incredible things in their career but
they're really eager to give back back
and to Mentor students the impact fund
really provides a strong Avenue to
explore impact investing and that was
one of my top reasons for coming to the
GSB you join a community of really
Mission oriented peers who are also
passionate about exploring the field of
impact investing one of the greatest
benefits of getting an MBA for me has
been both expanding your realm of
possibility or your understanding of
what can exist in the world and then
giving you the tools to actually pursue
it and make it happen one class in
particular that was really great was the
entrepreneurship from diverse
perspectives class they bring in a lot
of entrepreneurs from various
backgrounds different socioeconomic
statuses different race and we were able
to see how their path to
entrepreneurship was different for each
of them I've been exposed to different
leading practitioners in the field who
come into our classes and and connect
with students and all of these different
courses have really influenced my
understanding understanding of the field
of impact and really how to drive impact
at skill I'm most proud of the fact that
a lot of students that come to the GSB
are pursuing non-traditional paths my
advice to people who are thinking of
getting an MBA at GSP is to really think
through that question the infamous
question that GSP asks what matters to
you most and why because that question
and your answer to that question will be
your guiding Northstar and will help you
figure out whether that is truly the
thing that you care most about